alors qui est très chiant c'est
d'attendre que ce chien de patientes et
d'ailleurs la stib et du faucon attend
un petit peu trop dans les loges où là
il a beaucoup des chroniqueurs gmt bnp
je ne fais pas par lequel commencer
allez on va dire comme je suis bonne
camarade d'abord un que j'aime beaucoup
delormeau et après tu as ta vie on était
donc lors de la fête de la musique je
sais plus dans le nord quelque part dans
le même hôtel et on s'est retrouvés le
matin au petit déj avec plein d'artistes
et notamment 20 33 et là il est venu
nous parler direct au jt pas encore
réveillé fini voilà on a bien approché
même si je n'ai pas comparé le matin ça
c'est chiant d'ailleurs aussi mais comme
par le matin quand j'ai pas vu monter
mais voilà on s'est rencontrés comme ça
sur une chantilly
comme par hasard alors je ne peux pas
être très classe mais moi ma chanson
préférée de francky vincent tu veux mon
zizi oui oui